[Applaus]
[Musik]
jahrelang war made in china ein synonym
für billig und praktisch zb sind
chinesische handys billiger als iphones
oder samsung modelle allerdings haben
nur wenige chinesische unternehmen
pionierarbeit in sachen neuer
technologie geleistet bis jetzt
[Musik]
ist weiterhin führend bei kommerziellen
5g verträgen ganz genau wir sprechen von
5 g also vom schnellen mobilen internet
20 mal schneller als 4g und das ist
nicht nur irgendwie so als politik
videos auf deinem handy schneller
herunter zu laden 5 gb wird zb auch
entscheidend dafür sein wie wir selbst
fahrende autos nutzen können wollte ich
weiß was viele von euch jetzt denken
werden huawei stellen die nicht nur
handys her ganz und gar nicht denn sie
produzieren vor allem auch die
basisstationen antennen und all die
notwendige hardware und die mobilfunk
und internet infrastruktur aufzubauen
jedes mal wenn du dein handy nimmst um
zu telefonieren zum essen oder auf
irgendeine weise das internet zu nutzen
verbindest du dich mit der
nächstgelegenen basisstationen
typischerweise werden diese von den
mobilfunkanbietern betrieben also von
firmen wie auch vodafone oder t-mobile
aber dieses jahr stellen die hardware
nicht selbst her sondern kaufen sie bei
nokia alcatel oder eben way und im
wettrennen um 5 g ist huawei das
führende unternehmen und du denkst jetzt
wahrscheinlich ok mag schön furore warum
sollte sich das jetzt überhaupt
interessieren nun fragen wir doch mal in
unseren alten bekannten gold
ist etwas das sehr gefährlich ist wenn
man sich anschaut was sich vom
sicherheits standpunkt aus getan haben
vom militärischen standpunkt aus ist das
sehr gefährlich
auch sein amtsnachfolger so ist der
selben meinung und denkt mal drüber nach
huawei ist ein chinesisches unternehmen
wie du weißt ist in china die grenze
zwischen regierung und wirtschaft
ziemlich sagen wir mal fließend und wir
reden hier über die installation von
kommunikations infrastruktur für ganze
städte unterländer und deswegen
befürchten beide us-präsidenten dass
china die amis über ihre eigenen
telefone ausspionieren könnte aber haben
sie damit wirklich recht nun es kommt
wieder mal darauf an wenn du fragst denn
der britische premier tourist chancen
war zunächst ein großer fan von huawei
er schickte chance sogar folgende
nachricht
wenn die leute erst gegen die eine oder
andere marke sind dann müssen sie uns
sagen was die alternative ist die frage
lautet also wie kann es überhaupt sein
dass jedes unternehmen das seinen um 5 g
anführt stellt das wirklich ein problem
dar oder ist dass es wieder nur ein
reines politikum und was noch wichtiger
ist wird china und wirklich
ausspionieren wollten wir diese fragen
beantworten aber lasst uns zuerst einen
kurzen blick in die geschichte der
[Musik]
unrentable technologie
im jahr 2009 waren oslo stockholm die
ersten beiden städte die 4g netze
einsetzen ein paar jahre später hatte
dann fast jeder zugang zum internet
[Musik]
die neue geschwindigkeit und qualität
der verbindung hat videotelefonate den
erfolg des sozialen netzwerke die
explosion von youtube und e commerce
ermöglicht und die frage ist was wird
aus 5g bringen nun 5g ist ein
telekommunikations standard der von der
international telecommunication union
einem un gremium definiert wird für die
fünf die technologie haben sie eigene
anforderungen festgelegt es muss
download geschwindigkeiten von
mindestens 20 gigabit pro sekunde
reaktionszeiten von weniger als einer
millisekunde und eine technologie bieten
die mindestens eine million geräte auf
einem quadratkilometer verbinden kann
was bedeutet das alles nun hauptsächlich
dass wir innerhalb dieser million geräte
nicht nur mobiltelefone haben werden wir
reden auch über selbstfahrende autos
fabriken und intelligente häuser
[Musik]
das ist die zukunft und wenn uns jemand
davon erzählen kann dann ren zhengfei
der chef von coop
in den nächsten zwanzig oder dreißig
jahren werden wir eine großartige
logische revolution erleben in der natur
eine informationsgesellschaft werden
automatisiert durch künstliche
intelligenz in gera von cloud und ki
werden wir ein exklusives datenwachstum
erleben dass die ein tsunami ausbricht
diese daten brauchen die unterstützung
durch die fortschrittlichsten geräte
tsunami riss mit anderen worten niemand
bestreitet dass fünf geht etwas sehr
gutes ist aber die frage ist ist es das
wirklich wert oder anders ausgedrückt
wie viel wird es kosten nun schon daraus
ein beispiel an spanien
[Musik]
im moment stehen in spanien 90.000 3g
und 4g basisstationen jede antenne
kostet etwa 75.000 euro ok du kannst
jetzt den taschenrechner ausholen aber
wenn du denkst dass diese antennen teuer
sind dann bedenke dass 5g noch viel
teurer sein sollte die mobilfunk netze
nutzen hochfrequente funkwellen und 5g
erfordert noch höhere frequenzbereiche
um ein noch höheres datenvolumen
übertragen zu können das problem ist
jedoch dass je höher die frequenz desto
schwieriger ist es der funkwellen
hindernisse zu überwinden und deswegen
wird eine höhere antennen dichte
notwendig und ich weiß was du jetzt
denkst was macht das überhaupt keinen
unterschied es handelt sich doch um eine
sichere investition in die zukunft wir
alle wollen doch schnelles internet ich
bin sicher dass die betreiber mit 5 g
einen reibach machen werden und meine
antwort darauf ist bist du dir sicher so
klar scheint dass nämlich gar nicht zu
sein die wahrheit ist nämlich nun mal
dass die meisten mobilfunkanbieter schon
mit vier die kaum ihre investitionen
reingeholt haben
tatsächlich haben sie sich erst jetzt
zehn jahre nach seiner einführung
langsam amortisiert denkt mal darüber
nach 5 gb wird es ihr ermöglichen einen
film in wenigen sekunden herunter zu
laden die frage ist aber ob du wirklich
einen film in ein paar sekunden
herunterladen muss ich meine mit 4g
kannst du ihn schon ein paar minuten
sehen ich denke nicht dass es einen
großen unterschied machen kann dies also
wirklich einen so großen bedarf auslösen
das gleiche gilt für selbstfahrende
autos ja sie sind fantastisch sie werden
eine revolution darstellen aber wann
wird es soweit sein dass die massenware
sind und millionenfach unterwegs sind so
dass sich die investitionen wirklich
rechnen in drei jahren 15 oder gar mehr
mit anderen worten die meisten dinge die
5g wirklich benötigen werden gibt es
noch nicht die technologie ist wunderbar
aber manchmal kann es sehr teuer werden
da man sich zu weit vorwagt und
seinerzeit einfach zu weit voraus ist
dem zb die olympischen spiele in tokio
ja ich weiß sie wurde wegen krone auf
2.021 geschoben aber wenn sich 2020
stattgefunden hätten wäre es das erste
große event gewesen dass eine auflösung
übertragen wurde die lte technologie
existiert bereits in vollem umfang sie
ist alles andere als billig allerdings
haben die meisten leute in ihren
wohnzimmern noch nicht mal auf
vorkehrung gestellt
das bedeutet das ja billig ist vermögen
zu etwas ausgibt was fast niemand nutzen
kann oder will applaus für japan all das
erklärt warum europäische unternehmen
firmen wie nokia oder alcatel kaum in 5g
investiert haben sie habe im grunde
genommen gesagt okay 5g ist die zukunft
aber das wird es noch eine weile bleiben
in der gegenwart haben wir andere sorgen
aber in china haben sie das gegenteil
getankt warum das uns gleich mal einen
blick drauf hast
[Musik]
artikel 7 in seltenen fällen ist china
so transparent wie bei der entscheidung
dass die entwicklung von 5 g eine
absolute priorität ist und du weißt die
peking mit seinem fünfjahrespläne
arbeitet sie haben eine zentralisierte
wirtschaft und sie haben gesagt lasst
uns sofort loslegen das kommunistische
regime hat also alles bild schnell in
bewegung gesetzt damit war eines seiner
aushängeschilder im clip moderation
sektor die fünf die entwicklung
vorantreiben kann wir kennen so was ja
von diesem sympathischen technologie
enthusiasten aus jurassic park der auch
mal gesagt wir haben keine kosten
gescheut
staatliche unterstützung hat hoher weg
zum globalen aufstieg verholfen china
steckt erhielt bis zu 75 milliarden
dollar an steuererleichterungen
finanzierung und belegen ressourcen als
er zum weltweit führenden
telekommunikationsanbieter wurde
heute ist der name weight muss allen
bekannt aber du solltest wissen das ist
nicht nur ein privates unternehmen
handelt das 1987 gegründet wurde es hat
also von einem doppelten boom
profitieren können dem
telekommunikations bogen um den boom der
chinesischen wirtschaft hat es geschafft
den riesigen chinesischen markt aus dem
stegreif zu erobern und den chinesen
praktisch aus dem nichts eine
vollwertige kommunikationsinfrastruktur
zu liefern bevor weil durch die usa mit
sanktionen belegt wurde stiegen sie gar
zum zweitgrößten handyhersteller der
welt auf der verkauf von smartphones ist
jedoch nur die hälfte ihres geschäfts
die andere hälfte ist die entwicklung
von mobilfunk netzen und weise die
chinesen echt spitze
huawei ist der unangefochtene
marktführer im bereich 5 hat einen
weltweiten marktanteil von 30 prozent
erreicht und deswegen wurde das zum
problem nun lasst uns hierzu einen
kurzen blick in die chinesischen
gesetzes bücher werfen dort finden wir
dann dinge wie diese
jede organisation oder jeder bürger soll
die arbeit der staatlichen
nachrichtendienste in übereinstimmung
mit dem gesetz unterstützen helfen und
mit ihr zusammenarbeiten
nach 37 des nationalen nachrichtendienst
gesetzes 2017 nun ja auch wenn huawei
jetzt abstreitet es ist klar dass die
chinesische regierung sie zum spionieren
zwingen kann und sie kann sich natürlich
auch dazu zwingen darüber gefälligst die
klappe zu halten wer sonst soll es endet
man die alibaba gründer jack ma oder
noch viel schlimmer aber es gibt da noch
etwas viel gefährlicheres bei einem
hypothetischen ernsten konflikt zwischen
china und einem lang das rohr beim
mobilfunk ausrüstung nutzt besteht das
große risiko nicht mehr darin dass
huawei nicht nur aus spüren jetzt denkt
mal drüber nach in einer welt in der
autos mit dem internet verbunden sind
fabriken übers internet komplett
gesperrt werden und sogar krankenhäuser
ohne internet nur eingeschränkt
handlungsfähig sind was wäre wenn china
hatten bei allen das im kriegsfall
einfach die kontrolle übernehmen könnte
und ja ich weiß was du es tags gegen bak
das klingt einer kruden mischung aus
science fiction und einer lächerlichen
verschwörungstheorie hör auf mit einem
anti chinesische wirbel nun das alles
mag heute noch undenkbar erscheinen aber
es gibt schon heute eine ganze reihe von
regierungen die auch derartig hirsch
wirbel und das alles sehr ernst nehmen
nein nicht nur die angst
[Musik]
daran schließt als letztes land huawei
und zte wegen sicherheitsbedenken von
der 5 1 führung aus
in europa ist diese gefahr vielen
regieren dann jedoch alles andere als
klar und warum nun das verraten wir
jetzt
[Musik]
harris versus donald s europa verfügt
eigentlich über führende unternehmen die
mobilfunknetze entwickeln und bauen
eriksson kommt aus schweden nokia
networks ist aus einem joint venture der
finnischen nokia und der deutschen
siemens hervorgegangen diese unternehmen
bieten ihre eigenen 5g systeme an aber
natürlich geht china mit einer ganz
anderen geschwindigkeit vor es baut die
infrastruktur viel aggressiver aus als
jeder andere auf der welt investiert
viel mehr und eine bedeutend höhere
abdeckung da bekommt halt so manche
nervöser lobbygetriebenen politiker
schon mal angst dass sein land den
anschluss verliert und diese angst
könnte größer sein als die von chinas
spionage gesetzes aber es gibt zwei
weitere dinge die wir nicht vergessen
dürfen die erste ist das schon seit zwei
jahrzehnten in europa tätig ist genau
viele der basisstationen ein handy mit
der welt verbinden wurden bereits von
huawei geliefert und was ist die zweite
sache die wir nicht vergessen dürfen nur
schau dir mal diese karte an
das ist die karte der länder mit
backdoor gesetzen das heißt in all den
ländern die du in rot ist kann die
regierung einen diensteanbieter dazu
zwingen seine kommunikation abzugreifen
diese gesetze wurden ursprünglich
eingeführt um gegen terroristen
ermitteln zu können die vereinigten
staaten haben solche gesetze frankreich
und das vereinigte königreich auch und
ich weiß was du mir sagen wirst mal
sehen markt von einer kommunistischen
diktatur ausspioniert zu werden ist
nicht dasselbe wie von den guten einer
demokratisch gewählten regierung wer von
dieser etwas zu verbergen hat führt doch
sicher nichts gutes im schilde und ja
gewisse unterschiede gibt es da ganz
sicher aber diese sind nun mal nicht
thema dieses videos denn was diese karte
und diese gesetze beweisen ist dass
nicht nur die chinesische regierung
unternehmen zwingt versteckte abo
möglichkeiten in ihr technisches
equipment einzubauen und auf eines
kritik gibt nehmen diese gesetz
existieren nicht nur einfach so auf dem
papier viele sicherheitsexperten sagen
dass ihre existenz der indirekte beweis
ist das ist diese backdoors wirklich
gegen muss so in den geräten westlicher
hersteller als eben auch base wieso also
haben die europäer so naiv reagiert nun
es geht vor allem um eine sache um geld
im moment die torwand mal das modernste
und billigste 50 cent an die viel
billiger nun im schnitt um 20 prozent
gegenüber den europäischen anbietern das
war ein königreich hat also noch eine
formel gesucht um in den genuss der
modernsten mobilfunkinfrastruktur zu
kommen gleichzeitig aber eine menge
kohle zu sparen und den sommer mit drums
nicht zu provozieren und ja lässt er es
war schon recht draufgängerisch stadt
großbritannien ja zur fünf ice allianz
gehört
[Musik]
packt der die vereinigten staaten kanada
das vereinigte königreich australien und
neuseeland umfasst diese allianz
überwacht die sicherheit der
elektronischen kommunikation weltweit
und von diesen fünf ländern wollten die
dritten als einzige die zusammenarbeit
mit huawei erlauben und du bist dich
jetzt fragen was ist hier los boris
johnson zurück geworden wurde er
bestochen
nun nichts von alldem ganz im gegenteil
das vereinigte königreich hat huawei
seit zehn jahren sehr genau beobachtet
in der tat wurde 2010 das cyber security
assessment center ganz in der nähe von
oxford gegründet aber das einzige was in
den letzten zehn jahren kritisiert haben
ist dass die software hätte besser
programmiert werden können ja sie haben
absolut nichts gefunden was mit spürnase
zu tun haben könnte und genau deswegen
wollte johnson einen kompromiss finden
um doch noch irgendwie diese sieben
milliarden pfund mit hilfe hoher weiß
sparen zu können immerhin ein
pappenstiel
großbritannien dort hoher weg laufen
fünf geht so liefert mit engen
einschränkungen da platzt den amis
endgültig der kragen drohte damit alle
geheimdienstlichen kooperation mit
ländern in denen man rays geht zum
einsatz kommt einfach abzubrechen
schließlich erließ er dann hat es
sanktionen gegenüber welche auch sein
nachfolger beiden beibehielt bestrafe
ländern die nicht bei hofe einkaufs
sogar einen kostenausgleich an quasi
einen gutschein wenn sie ihr 5g woanders
shoppen gehen johnson setzte daraufhin
den rückwärtsgang ein angesichts der us
sanktionen seien keinerlei grundlage
mehr weiter mit hoher welt
zusammenzuarbeiten die chinesen sind nun
von der insel verbannt
so wie sieht es aber woanders aus auch
in deutschland wird angela merkel schon
sehr lange mit hoher wellen bau der
deutschen messe es war hat der bundestag
im april 2011 sollen sich ein neues
sicherheitsgesetz erlassen welches den
ausschluss eines anbieters bei
sicherheitsbedenken ermöglicht aber ob
dies wirklich gegen nur welt zum tragen
kommt steht in den sternen die deutsche
telekom huawei ist größter kunde in
europa hat sich ausdrücklich gegen ein
generelles verbot für einzelne
ausländische anbieter ausgesprochen in
der schweiz teilte der bundesrat mit
dass bisher keine beweise für die league
gegen marokko spionage vorwürfe
vorliegen würden für die schweizer ist
ein vorteil nicht von
sicherheitspolitischen unabhängig zu
sagen die anderen länder dazu zwingen
für die eine oder andere seite partei zu
ergreifen mehrere schweizer
netzbetreiber bauen ihre fünf die
infrastruktur daher mit hoher bay und
auch in österreich 35 die netze munter
von huawei gebaut von misstrauen
zwischen wien und peking keine spur
daher ist die frage jetzt an dich
gerichtet wie sollten sich deiner
meinung nach aus der länder gegenüber
huawei positionieren ist das eingesparte
geld das risiko fährt oder ist es gar
das beste einfach alle geheimdienste mit
ihrem rektors unterschiedslos ins land
zu lassen ohne einen bestimmten zu
diskriminieren nach dem motto sollen sie
doch alle mithören teilt eure meinung
bitte wie immer mit uns und auch allen
anderen im diskussionsbereich ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat
falls ihr ergebnis bitte ein leichtes
mit euren freunden und vergesst nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren und auch das
glück nicht so aktivieren damit er
keines unserer zukünftigen videos
verpasst was gut und bis bald
[Musik]